[Musik]
wo sonst auf der welt kann man so leben
weiß ist magisch in dubai ist selbst ein
schlechter tag in wirklichkeit ein guter
tag
dubai eine menschengemachte oase in der
arabischen wüste
[Musik]
heimat von rund 70.000 millionären wie
viel an taschen haben sie keine ahnung
gefälschte dabei gefälschte
zweieinhalb millionen einwanderer würden
sie darin eine zigarre rauchen wenn ich
eine hätte
sie fotografieren frauen an schönen
orten ja willkommen in dubai
orient trifft okzident
einmal ging ich mit knie freien brock in
die mall und bekam die rote karte
gezeigt freiheit trifft auf verbote ich
sage lieber nichts ich lebe gerne hier
ein paradies für alle die bereit sind
sich an regeln zu halten
[Musik]
dubai das sind reiche emirat ihs experte
touristen und ein heer von
arbeitsmigranten ohne die
aufmerksamkeiten aus 24 karat gold wäre
es kein richtiges bad
[Musik]
du kannst du tun als wärst du milliardär
aber nach diesem essen wird eine woche
lang schmalhans küchenmeister sein
ein angesagter luxus spielplatz für die
mega reichen
dubai ist das monaco des nahen ostens
jeder will hier sein
[Musik]
märz in dubai
mit steigenden temperaturen suchen die
einheimischen vermehrt schattige plätze
auf während die touristen und
sonnenanbeter gar nicht genug sonne
kriegen können
[Musik]
die schillernde metropole ist wie von
zauberhand aus der arabischen wüste
empor gewachsen
flächenmäßig kaum größer als
fürstenfeldbruck leben hier heute mehr
als zweieinhalb millionen sonnenhungrige
experts
was wir an dubai wirklich schätzen ist
dass man hier seinen wohlstand
problemlos genießen kann
gamers gott pendelt zwischen dubai und
jersey hin und her sie hat einen der
reichsten männer auf der britischen
kanalinsel geheiratet
der makler erzählte uns dass david und
victoria beckham die villa gemietet
hatten als david auf dem weg zur fußball
wm in japan war der gedanke dass david
und victoria unter unserer dusche und in
unserem schlafzimmer waren ist doch sehr
amüsant
die scotts wohnen in emmerichs hills
einem der begehrtesten vororte knapp
zehn kilometer vom meer entfernt
die siedlung ist eine ansammlung
millionenschwerer willen inmitten von
künstlichen seen und gepflegten grün
es ist eine sehr exklusive gegend eine
geschlossene wohnanlage mit viel
privatsphäre
sicher eine der angesagtesten lagen in
dubai als wir kamen waren wir sofort
begeistert
neben allerlei promis und fußballprofis
haben auch weniger ruhmreiche
persönlichkeiten emirates hills zu ihrer
heimat gemacht
dass hier an der ecke gehört der mugabe
familie
silvester lassen die es immer so richtig
knallen
dubai ist traditionell bei expert sehr
beliebt dubai ist eines der sieben
scheichtümer die sich entlang der küste
australiens südlich des arabischen golfs
erstrecken
in den 70er und 80er jahren kommen viele
her um auf den großen baustellen zu
arbeiten
ich finde die landschaft ziemlich
eintönig sand sand und nochmals sand
in den 90er und 2000er jahren ziehen die
neu entstandenen luxusimmobilien und
ganzjähriger sonnenschein millionäre aus
aller welt an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen in unserer villa
dieses zimmer gefällt mir besonders gut
ich habe es in den landesfarben der
emirate dekoriert die farben der flagge
finden sich zum beispiel hier in diesen
blumen wieder
auch den kronleuchter liebe ich die
kristalle habe ich alle selbst
ausgewählt die sind handverlesen alle in
den farben der emirate
dubai ist berühmt für seine designermode
luxustempel in denen nahezu alle wünsche
der schönen und reichen erfüllt werden
können
[Musik]
unsere rettungsringe sind von meinen
lieblingsmarken hermès und chanel sie
funktionieren tatsächlich falls wir mal
welche brauchen
20 kilometer entfernt am anderen ende
der stadt liegt der luxus vor ort dubai
hills in einer der bis zu 20 millionen
euro teuren villen lebt diese schweizer
shopping queen läuft schon
opa du okay ich bin bereit sonja bronk
das hier nennen wir die showküche
hier frühstücken wir mit den kindern und
hier
das nennen wir die
die schmuddel küche
aber wie sie sehen ist sie nicht
schmuddelig also eine küche zum
richtigen kochen
ja hier kochen wir auch manchmal
sie ist nett anzusehen
und man kann ja auch kochen nun nichts
was riecht
was geben sie für so eine flasche wein
aus
das kommt darauf an das schlimmste an
mir ist dass ich mir die preise so
schlecht merken kann
[Musik]
der
aufzug oder treppe was möchten sie
trippeln
sonja prompt kam vor vier jahren mit
ihrem millionenschweren ehemann einem
investor nach dubai ist das ist für
meine schuhe meine favoriten sind ganz
klar diese gucci mit plateausohle
diese
lg mit plateausohle alle gleich aber
verschiedene farben
es gab eine zeit da liebte ich die es so
lohre
denn die sind echt bequem
ich denke bei diesen hier wird jede frau
mit gehen wenn man die trägt weiß man
wie gut man sich mit plateausohle fühlt
aber jetzt sind absatzschuhe wieder in
also die klassische form sind zwar
schmerzhaft aber muss man sagen es teilt
die mode
sehr schön oder ich liebe sie
flache schuhe absätze darüber könnte ich
stundenlang reden hier sind von prada
absoluter wahnsinn
ich habe sie in schwarz und weiß gekauft
weil sie anfangs schwer zu bekommen
waren
was kosten die wie viel der preis keine
ahnung
ich habe hormon probleme können wir
nichts merken
sonja schuhe haben einen wert von mehr
als
230.000 euro in ihrem schrank hat sie
sogar eine handtaschen abteilung
eine schöne tasche ist das a und o wenn
du ein schönes paar schuhe hast in die
tasche ist horror
geht gar nicht
wie viele handtaschen augen sehen keine
ahnung ich spüre ich weiß es nicht
das sind noch mehr kellys habe ich dich
mitgezählt tut mir leid
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
sind gefällt steht aber 20 was meinen
sie mit gefälscht sind durch gefälschte
dabei
[Musik]
mein gott ich hasse diese fälschungen
ich weiß nicht wie die leute
ich meine hier dass wir machen was er
will aber ich nicht auch wenn die mir
nichts kaufen
meine freunde machen sowas nicht
zumindest hoffe ich das für sie
mit einem geschätzten wert von nahezu
fünf millionen euro ist sonja bronx
garderobe fast so viel wert wie das
ganze haus
ja ist okay was sie hier danke
männer
hallo um wieviel möchten sie abendessen
einnehmen
in etwa 30 minuten 30 minuten wie lange
brauchen sie ghana hat ihre neuen
nachbarn zum essen eingeladen paul und
anna sind gerade erst hierher gezogen
probiert die köstlichen arabischen
snacks die unsere köche käse zubereitet
hat solange sie noch heiß sind sie sind
unglaublich
toll aus das ist alles typisch arabisch
mit dabei sind auch ihre vierjährige
tochter jenny und ihr 22 jähriger sohn
denn bei einer köchin wie hazel fällt es
schwer schlank zu bleiben sie ist
unglaublich echte herausforderung
das ist wirklich gut billiges personal
gehört zu den vielen annehmlichkeiten
die experts an dubai schätzen
unser philippinisches team ist
fantastisch
wir haben viele frauen ein kindermädchen
eine köchin eine fahrerin und eine
haushälterin sie sind super wir schätzen
ihre hilfe sehr
gamers privat köchin hazel sorgt für das
leibliche wohl
ich liebe dieses gericht
es ist schon sehr weit
es schmeckt wirklich lecker
unsere mitarbeiter leben alle bei uns im
haus ich denke wir behandeln sie sehr
gut fragen sie sie werden es ihnen
bestätigen alles ist inbegriffen kost
und logis alles was sie brauchen
der mindestlohn für eine hausangestellte
beträgt 1.500 die rams
knapp 400 euro pro monat
aber wir zahlen viel mehr als den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn in dubai weil
wir sowohl
was wirst du mit kuchen
das ist ein sehr leckere kuchen
schokoladenkuchen
der lieblingskuchen unserer kleinen
prinzessin
nicht anfassen
nicht anfassen gibt es später wenn er
nur ein bisschen zuckerguss
[Musik]
später
noch ein großes stück haben aber zum
nachtisch okay
woher hast du ihn nicht an
es ist toll hier die leute sind
wunderbar
sie wollen wirklich arbeiten um ihre
familien zu hause zu unterstützen
sie haben richtig lust zu arbeiten
das passt alles sehr gut denke ich
95 prozent der kinder in dubai werden
von ausländischen kindermädchen betreut
das ist schon die dritte linie eine
nanny
ich hatte eine banane genie wie viele
bananen hast du gegessen
4 wie sagt man 4 auf arabisch araber war
banane
entschuldigung das ist brillant gut
gemacht
wasch dir die hände bevor wir uns an den
tisch setzen linda kannst du mit ihr
hände waschen gehen dann setzen wir uns
an den tisch danke
es ist toll ohne kindermädchen hätte ich
nicht noch ein kind bekommen
ohne kindermädchen geht hier gar nichts
welches davon ist philippinisch dass
dieses so sieht toll aus
ich habe auch einige libanesische
speisen gekocht ich habe früh in beirut
gearbeitet da sollte man lieber keinen
fehler machen selbst ein kleiner fehler
ist dort ein großer fehler man wird
regelrecht bloßgestellt die denken sie
können sich alles erlauben und man würde
ohnehin zu viel geld verdienen
weiß
na gut man ich bin wirklich gern sie
bedanken sich tausendmal bei mir alles
ist sehr herzlich das macht mich
glücklich
sein leben sei nicht immer so aus ich
bin in stoke-on-trent steffi
aufgewachsen in den englischen midlands
in einer ganz normalen arbeiterfamilie
bestimmt werden einige meiner
schulkameraden heute sagen guckt euch
die an für wen hält die sich lebt in
dubai mit ihren angestellten aber ich
hatte glück viele von uns hatten einfach
glück ich bilde mir nicht ein etwas
besonderes zu sein ich hatte einfach
wird
diesel hat einen kuchen extra für paul
und eterna gebacken
[Musik]
in dubai gibt es dutzende luxuriöse
wohnanlage
am bekanntesten ist die pensionäre eine
künstliche insel in form einer palme
sie wurde auf betreiben des herrschers
von dubai scheich mohammed bin raschid
al maktoum gebaut die palmen zweige sind
von millionenschweren villen gesäumt
alle mit eigenem strand
der halbmondförmige wellenbrecher soll
verhindern dass die palme ins meer
gespült wird er ist mit luxushotels und
resorts bebaut oh mein gott diese solle
da weißt du dass du in dubai ist oder
ramallah tief ist reisejournalist seinen
urlaub verbringt er in einem der fünf
sterne resort auf der palmeninsel jetzt
geht's los da haben wir der arabische
sand hier ist er ich glaube der sand
wurde aus italien importiert ob sie es
glauben oder nicht
schließlich sind wir in dubai
die zimmer preise starten bei 500 euro
pro nacht persönliche betreuung
inbegriffen
wie geht's schön dich zu sehen
danke schira
blind ist begleitet ihn ein
rettungsschwimmer an den strand haben
wie rewe oder flut ich denke wir haben
jetzt flut na toll frank ist einer von
20.000 nigerianern die in den emiraten
leben
er soll sich wohlfühlen wie alle anderen
auch er soll zufrieden sein
sie mögen sie ihre arbeit ja natürlich
ich mag es mit gästen wie amar spaß zu
haben
ich versuche ihm das gefühl zu geben
nicht anders zu sein als die anderen
der soll sich ganz normal fühlen deshalb
begleite ich ihn ins wasser und sorge
dafür dass er einen schönen tag hat
frank hat einen doktortitel in nigeria
hatte er einen guten job aber hier in
dubai kann er als rettungsschwimmer das
dreifache verdienen
es ist cool oder
er hat einen doktor als industrie
chemiker und hat 14 jahre lang und
verrichtet
aber heute habe ich ihnen ganz für mich
alleine
warum habe ich solche angst komm schon
krebsleiden
oh
mein gott ich glaube er weist mich
nein das ist hier kann ich sachen machen
die für blinde normalerweise schwierig
sind ich wohne in einem schönen hotel
ihr schwimmen
[Musik]
mein gott da ist er
[Gelächter]
mir
hier kann ich alles haben jeder gibt
sich mühe und jeder hilft dir
hier vergesse ich fast dass ich blind
bin
[Musik]
ein stück weiter an der spitze der palme
steht das atlantis eine 1500 zimmer
trutzburg
ein luxus monolith aus pink gold und
marmor
das atlantis ist heute eines der
wahrzeichen von dubai geworden der
inbegriff von extravaganz und luxus doch
es ist noch gar nicht so lange her dass
dubai auf keiner touristischen landkarte
zu finden war
[Applaus]
wir sind hier in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten 7 reiche
scheichtümer am südlichen ufer des
arabischen golfs hier gibt es alles was
das touristen hat begehrt aber aus
irgendeinem grund ist kaum jemand hier
glamour suchte man zu der zeit
vergeblich in dubai
aber das wollten die scheichs ändern aus
dem wüsten königreich sollte ein
reiseziel werden über das die ganze welt
spricht
eine säule dieses plans ist das atlantis
2008 wird es eröffnet dubai lässt es
krachen
schaut her atlantis steigt empor
ein spektakel wie es die welt noch nicht
gesehen hat
2000 promis aus aller welt werden für
das event eingeflogen einige erhalten
für ihre teilnahme bis zu eine million
euro die party wird ein
jahrhundertereignis und dubai ist
endlich in aller munde
seitdem arbeitet das hotel beständig
daran seinen platz im rampenlicht nicht
zu verlieren sei es durch die posts der
reichen und berühmten
hallo hallo
oder als kulisse für das reality-tv oma
in gott was für eine schönheit
war
ich den instagram flur viele unserer
gäste stellen sich hier als erstes hin
und machen ein foto von der decke und
natürlich den kronleuchtern das ist
wirklich etwas ganz besonderes
denn kümmert sich um die superreichen
gäste im atlantis heute bereitet er die
teuerste suite des hotels auf die
ankunft eines gastes vor
letzte kontrollen mit dem zimmerservice
wir kurz alle zimmer überprüfen
[Musik]
hoops
nichts passiert weitermachen
[Musik]
drei schlafzimmer zwei bäder 1 für ihn
einst für sie wahrlich zum mülleimer
kein staub ein bilder zimmer
panoramablick und ein preis der respekt
einflößt
die suite kostet über 20.000 euro pro
nacht die rechnungen gehen oft in die
hunderttausende
[Musik]
das auge aber
ich denke eine hohe rechnung spiegelt
eine großartige erfahrung wieder das
ganze ist sein geld wert
an diesem luxussegment kommt es vor dass
gäste die möbel austauschen oder auch
ihre eigenen bilder aufhängen lassen
ja
bestimmte lebensmittel und getränke
lassen wir aus der ganzen welt
einfliegen in diesem winkel ja
denn häufig seien es gab bislang keinen
extra wunsch den wir nicht erfüllt
hätten
in dieser sache hier sind goldstücke 18
karat gold stücke
was wäre ein badezimmer ohne 24 karat
gold feuchtigkeitscreme
man arbeitet tatsächlich blattgold in
die cremes ein das dann als peeling für
die haut fungiert
fühlt sich gleich besser einfach glatter
das ganze art mit einfach luxus man
spürt sofort dass diese annehmlichkeiten
nicht alltäglich sind
eine unvergessliche erfahrung
22 stockwerke tiefer wird gerade ein
festmahl zubereitet
das ist unser küchenchef er zaubert
heute morgen das essen für uns
diese köstlichkeiten sind nicht für die
normalen hotelgäste sondern für die
bewohner des hoteleigenen aquariums
[Musik]
in diesem vier stockwerke hohen becken
tummeln sich über 65.000 fische es ist
das herzstück des hotels
unsere tiere sind verwöhnt und werden
gut versorgt wärs wählerischer fisch
oder gast wahrscheinlich die fische
[Musik]
die stachelrochen fangen schon an zu
kreisen
die fische sind eine der
hauptattraktionen für die jährlich
500.000 gäste des hotels
das ist wie katzen füttern sobald du
vater hast kommen sie an katzen sind
aber geduldiger als stachelrochen
das aquarium gehört zu den
meistfotografierten motiven in ganz
dubai und das atlantis ist im instagram
ranking regelmäßig unter den meist
geposteten hotels der welt
chefbutler brian fowler muss seine vip
gäste rund um die uhr bei laune halten
heute ist seine aufgabe besonders
knifflig um den gäste kindern etwas
besonderes zu bieten will er ein
spielzeug genau vor ihren augen schweben
lassen
ich habe verstärkung mitgebracht falls
erwünscht
danke sollte ihm dieses kunststück
gelingen und die gäste würden darüber
berichten wäre das ein echter
marketingcoup solche
überraschungsmomente haben bei instagram
einen echten mehrwert ich kenne kein
anderes hotel dass so etwas macht das
wäre ein schönes ausrufezeichen bei
instagram
schauen sie
fehlen ein paar ballons gar nicht so
einfach sie zum schweben zu bringen
fehlen vielleicht drei oder vier
angesichts der großen konkurrenz auf dem
dubaier hotelmarkt muss das atlantis
sich stets neu erfinden um
zahlungskräftige gäste anzulocken
arcor natürlich haben unsere gäste einen
butler der rund um die uhr für sie da
ist er sehr wird einen wodka martini
oder einen spot on drugs je nachdem was
man bevorzugt das ist schon ein bisschen
besser als eine 08 15 minibar im
atlantis ist eben alles ein bisschen
größer und beeindruckender
sind die getränke im preis enthalten
oder muss man dafür extra bezahlen
hier muss man für alles bezahlen
in diesem leben ist fast nichts umsonst
dementsprechend machen wir unsere preise
hey hey ihr könntet ihr nochmal in die
bridge suite kommen
und eine große leiter mitbringen
[Musik]
ja wenn ihr zeit habt danke
das atlantis ebenso wie die vielen
anderen hotels an denen die regierung
zum teil direkt beteiligt ist spülen
jedes jahr satte mehrwertsteuereinnahmen
in die staatskasse allein für hotels und
restaurants geben die besucher pro jahr
über 20 milliarden euro aus
[Musik]
ein warmer regen der den bürgern du
beißt direkt zugute kommt
[Musik]
wenn ein emirati heiratet bekommt er
einen pauschalbetrag vom staat geschenkt
das rentenalter beginnt bereits mit 49
und das benzin für die luxusschlitten
ist selbstverständlich großzügig
subventioniert
doch nur wenige haben zugang zu diesem
exklusiven club nur wer die emiratische
staatsbürgerschaft hat oder einen
waschechten emirati heiratet kommt in
den genuss dieser üppigen zuwendungen
in dubai sind das weniger als 34.000
oder 15 prozent der bevölkerung die
anderen 85 prozent sind arbeitsmigranten
und expats ohne anspruch auf eine
staatsbürgerschaft sie müssen für die
schule ihre kinder bezahlen und eine
private krankenversicherung abschließen
verlieren sie ihren arbeitsplatz müssen
sie das land verlassen
[Musik]
das ist adele farooq
sie haben keinen schlüssel zu ihrem
eigenen hause nein als gebürtiger
emirati genießt er die vielen
privilegien die ihm sein status bietet
salam aleikum
hallo
so verbringt er die nachmittage stets
mit seinen söhnen
das sind meine beiden jüngeren mann ist
der freche stimme ins
mikro sag's ihnen da sagst du kannst
lauter sprechen ja
er ist der herr im haus
dell hat sein haus auf einem grundstück
gebaut dass ihm die regierung geschenkt
hat
als emirate kann man ein stück land
beantragen und bekommt das dann auch
einfach so wenn man heiratet erhält man
zusätzlich einen geldbetrag um die
heirat zu finanzieren plus ein stück
land dazu
spielen wir
die meiste zeit zu hause ich hole ihn
von der schule ab und er macht seine
hausaufgaben online und dann nimmt der
koran unterricht
wenn wir zeit haben daddeln wir auf der
xbox oder ps 5 und haben einfach spaß
er ist der champion
seht ihr in dubai gehen weniger als die
hälfte der emirates im erwerbsfähigen
alter einer festen beschäftigung nach
als gebürtiger emirate konnte adele es
sich leisten seinen job bei der
regierung aufzugeben er hat andere
prioritäten
[Musik]
einer karriere als sänger
weißt du bist einzigartig als emirate
hat man von geburt an anspruch auf
zahlreiche privilegien
das ist das schöne an diesem land
deshalb ist jeder emirate dem man
begegnet zufrieden mit den herrschern
zufrieden mit seiner heimat und deshalb
floriert das land
[Musik]
das ist rashid ball hassa 19 jahre hatte
ich jeden tag geburtstag
der junge emirati ist dubais reichste
teenager
der sohn eines milliardenschweren bau
moduls ist zugleich einer der
beliebtesten influenza des landes seine
fans kennen ihn als mann eex
er jordan 13 mit 13 machen ihn videos
über seine sneaker sammlung berühmt auch
mariah carey ist beeindruckt da fehlen
einem die worte und bevor er überhaupt
den führerschein macht hier ist man eqix
mit einem weiteren video
präsentiert er seinen dreieinhalb
millionen followern seine vielen
supersportwagen mantide das an das erste
auto der welt
[Applaus]
heute bringt rashid sein lieblingsauto
zum pimpen in die werkstatt ein 300.000
euro teurer
jetzt gut alles gut bei der man wirklich
aber ich liebe dieses autos manche sagen
es sei ein auto für alte männer aber ich
finde es einfach stil vor das ist ein
perfektes alltagsauto
40 so cool man fühlt sich wie auf
rashid youtube-kanal nimmt fahrt auf als
er anfängt videos über die folierung
seiner supersportwagen zu drehen
dieses auto an
doch mitunter bringen ihm seine clips
auch ärger ein
kürzlich hatte er eine seiner autos mit
dem typischen design eines
internationalen modehauses überzogen
die firma hat sich gemeldet und meinte
ich solle das wieder ab mache
ich habe gesagt ja klar ich will ja
keine probleme mit dem
diese bilder dürfen aus
urheberrechtlichen gründen nicht gezeigt
werden auch muster rashid die videos aus
den sozialen medien lassen jetzt kann
ich meinen kindern erzählen dass diese
firma sich bei mir gemeldet hat ist
auch super
werkstattbesitzer thaler hilft ihm etwas
weniger kontroverses zu finden
du entscheidest welche farbe wir haben
hunderte
wir sind super alle welche findest du am
besten das ist eine lieblingsfarbe meine
lieblingsfarbe ist grün
mein auto würde ich so auch nicht lag er
fragt mich nach meiner lieblingsfarbe
rot ist toll ich würde nichts anderes
nehmen bot ein rolls vielleicht lieber
blau rolls dunkelblau das ist es das
würde mega aussehen
bevor jemand anders die idee klaut
warum die farbe darum weil wir anders
sind weil er gern anders sein wollen wir
mögen verrückte farben die sonst niemand
hat
wir sind gern einzigartig das hast du
buy darum geht es in dubai einzigartig
zu sein habe ein rolls royce haben viele
aber wenn deine eine schöne oder sogar
krasse farbe hat sehen sich alle hälse
nachdem
sie verringerten sich die hälse
darum geht es wenn du an ihnen vorbei
fährst genick gebrochen
[Gelächter]
wird schwarz verchromt genau wie der
frontgrill ganz schwarz verchromt rund
um dieses mal bitte schön stilvoll
werden sich drehen auf jeden fall es
wird anders sein als die anderen ganz
anders das wird fantastisch
der beste überhaupt
keine sorge man qualität braucht zeit
es wird eine woche dauern bis rashid
auto fertig ist bis dahin bekommt er
einen leihwagen die sind zwar nicht
teuer fahren sich aber großartig ist
nagelneu die sitze sind noch verpackt
wurde erst vor ein paar tagen geliefert
dass es nagelneu ist damit wirst du
keinerlei probleme haben
aber welcher milliardär würde sich schon
in einen kia picanto setzen
danke für ein problem man jederzeit es
dann so lange sein auto in der werkstatt
ist wird rashid talas privat autofahren
einen 200.000 euro teuren mercedes g 65
ein tolles auto zum rumfahren wir machen
hier keine halben sachen
[Musik]
bei einem kunden wie rashid lässt das
team alles stehen und liegen
doch wer in dubai wirklich eindruck
machen will braucht mehr als nur eine
knallige folierung
das ist aber aus indien
ihr name steht auf dem haus ich bin
stolz auf mich
zwar sehr gültig ich habe meine ziele
schon sehr früh erreicht abu saabal hat
erst kürzlich für aufsehen in dubai
gesorgt denn er hat sich eines der
begehrtesten statussymbole überhaupt
gekauft nicht etwa diesem 300.000 euro
rolls royce sondern das teuerste
nummernschild der welt als ich nach
dubai kam stellte ich fest dass es eine
sehr seltsame statistik ging einmal in
ein hotel bekam aber kein zimmer obwohl
ich ein schönes auto hatte ich fragte
warum und man sagte mir ich müsste ein
schönes nummernschild haben ich fragte
ein schönes nummernschild wie soll das
aussehen sie sagten einst mit zwei
stellen
interessant also besorgte ich mir ein
paar nummernschilder das war mein erstes
48 49 di 27 und dann das war die beste
die nummer 5
ist das nummernschild mehr wert als das
auto
selbstverständlich das auto kostet
800.000 dollar das nummernschild 9
millionen gut acht millionen euro
am besten wäre natürlich die nummer eins
aber die kann man macht kaufen wer hatte
der könig
scheich mohammed
scheich mohammeds ist der
uneingeschränkte herrscher des emirats
dubai
nichts geschieht hier ohne sein plazet
[Musik]
er wird gleichermaßen verehrt und
gefürchtet
in dubai ist er allgegenwärtig
schon sein vater hatte die vision aus
der kleinen hafenstadt am persischen
golf eine der modernsten städte der welt
zu machen
scheich mohammed hat ein geschätztes
vermögen von 12 milliarden dollar
kritik an seiner person ist bei strafe
verboten
selbst friedlicher politischer protest
wird mit geld oder freiheitsstrafen
geahndet
die stadt ist komplett videoüberwacht
und der geheimdienst belauscht
gerüchtehalber sogar privatgespräche
besucher und einwohner müssen also
aufpassen was sie sagen
zwar leben die emiratis in frieden doch
die region gleicht einem pulverfass
2011 und zwölf erschüttern revolutionen
und proteste große teile der arabischen
welt
in den nachbarländern der emirate
greifen unruhen um sich
während in dubai business as usual
herrscht
in ägypten tunesien oder syrien bricht
der tourismus ein
doch in dubai geht das glamouröse leben
weiter als wäre nichts geschehen
die emirates haben keinen grund auf die
straße zu gehen und ihre angestellten
sind darauf erpicht ihrer
aufenthaltsgenehmigungen nicht aufs
spiel zu setzen
gibt es auch kritiker
warum wozu er macht ja nichts falsch
würden sie ihn wählen es ging um jedes
mal jedes mal immer wieder
solange die geschäfte laufen hat der
scheich sein volk hinter sich das
bedeutet aber auch die maschine will
immer gut geölt sein
dass mir eine dubai gefällt ist dass man
hier geschäft und lebensstil gut
miteinander verbinden kann
wer hart arbeitet und gut verdient muss
sich nicht verstecken
der dänische geschäftsmann martin
pedersen ist einer der rund 70.000
millionäre in dubai man kann es sich
hier einfach gut gehen lassen niemand
guckt ich scharf an weil du einen rolls
royce hast oder ein bentley oder zwölf
ganz egal
tatsächlich nennt petersen 12 sein eigen
sie parken im fünf sterne hotel al haq
tour palace in dem er auch wo
das ist ein neuer bentley gtc er ist
wahnsinnig schnell ich fühle mich damit
viel jünger ist in einem rolls royce es
ist gut für mein ego wenn ich den fahrer
wenn man mit so einem auto in europa
fährt gucken einen die leute schief an
wenn ich das gleiche auto in dänemark
parken würde das würde ich
wahrscheinlich verprügelt werden oder so
martin pedersen kommt aus einer
kleinstadt in dänemark vor zwölf jahren
ist er mit seiner familie nach dubai
gezogen
da ist eine menge adrenalin im spiel
das problem ist wahrscheinlich der
midlife crisis geschuldet die manche
männer heimsucht einige sammeln uhren
briefmarken oder autos ich sammle autos
fuhren und wein
[Musik]
petterson ist hauptsponsor einer der
exklusivsten veranstaltungen im nahen
osten dem polo gold cup tickets sind nur
schwer zu ergattern
seit mehr als zwei wochen ausverkauft
hier kommt nur rein wer schwer reich ist
oder zu dubais glamouröser schickeria
gehört
hier sehen sie von hier bis da hinten
und weiter darunter rammelvoll
der sport ist ihr nur kulisse
sind bandidos die beste kombination aus
geschäft vergnügen und jugend
du weißt versammelte prominenz findet
sich in der vip lounge ein bei einem
glas champagner wird das ein oder andere
geschäft eingetütet ein anstrengender
tag ich muss unbedingt mein anzug
wechseln ich schwitze es ist so heiß
heute
lieber wasser
die glauben nur weil ich aus dänemark
kommt trinke ich die ganze zeit nur weil
aber heute ist arbeitstag
cocktails häppchen und partystimmung der
typische dubai mix
das beste an dubai ist
steuerfreiheit
mit anderen worten geld
[Musik]
alles fein geschnitten ein heer von
köchen sorgt dafür dass millionäre wie
pettersson geschäft und vergnügen
perfekt kombinieren können ist gut so
die polo küche beschäftigt mitarbeiter
aus aller welt ich komme aus nebra
ich mir mal ich
komme aus indien auch sie träumen davon
eines tages groß rauszukommen
was gefällt ihnen an der arbeit beim
polo kommen die ganzen autos
so schnell und sexy ich mag ferraris
nicht jeder dringt in den erlauchten
kreis der superreichen vor aber viele
schaffen es zumindest so auszusehen
instagram kann jeder so aussehen als
wäre er milliardär aber nach dem essen
ist bei mir wieder schmalhans
küchenmeister
vor lauter glamour ist es für den laien
kaum zu erkennen wer reich ist und wer
nur so tut
danke wir sehen uns wenn wir zurück sind
es sei denn man wohnt in emmerichs hills
schön die tasche rein heute morgen hat
ghana zwei limousinen für den trip zum
flughafen bestellt so danke
die familie fliegt mit dem privatjet zu
ihrem anderen zu hause auf jersey
keiner fährt mit ihrem sohn denn tochter
jenny und ihr vater nehmen die andere
limousine
[Musik]
ja ich liebe den spiegel ich verstehe
nicht warum man traut ist das nicht
haben wir ladies brauchen das auch
[Musik]
im privatjet bleibt kein wunsch
unerfüllt
mein gott so viel
service managerin mariana lädt 25 tüten
mit knabberzeug sein damit die familie
auf dem achtstündigen flug nicht hunger
leiden muss
und noch mehr
unsere kunden sind die absoluten
topteams
da ist kein platz für fehler die
erwartungen sind sehr hoch effektiv und
dafür eine menge stress aber ich liebe
es
hallo guten morgen wie geht es ihnen gut
danke kommen dubais high society
erwartet nicht nur guten service sondern
auch tolle überraschungen jetzt will ich
gar nicht mehr weg
eine konzertpianistin erfreut gaynor mit
ihrem lieblingslied selbst die
erfrischungen haben eine persönliche
note
mein gott ich glaube es nicht das bin ja
ich
fliegen macht mich immer sehr nervös
deshalb tut sowas hier richtig gut
davon muss ich ein foto machen
die ablenkungen beruhigt mich ich denke
nicht soviel an die hektik auf dem
flughafen und all die menschen in der
maschine
die besorgt uns bitte eine maschine
damit wir zu hause auch unsere fotos auf
dem kaffee haben können
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo
auch gegners angestellte können sich
heute einen freien tag wenn auch nicht
ganz so noble
hazel trifft sich mit anita gamers
haushälterin mach es so in little manila
30 kilometer von rio entfernt genießen
sie den geschmack der heimat
eine stunde ist wirklich breit
wir sind hier in einem philippinischen
restaurant vermissen
ich glaube sie haben an den
philippinischen koch die folge die
filipinos nennen das hier prinzip für
die meisten von uns wie es dass das
lieblingsessen
ich habe anita gefragt wie es schmeckt
sie sagte es
ist besser
ich sag das jetzt lieber nicht so laut
aber anita das gesagt weil ich immer für
alle körper
[Musik]
den freien tag verbringen die
philippinischen hausangestellten gern in
little manila
ein beliebter zeitvertreib shopping in
den secondhand läden was kostet das
das mit dem aufdruck nicht runter
gesessen günstig
die läden werden uke genannt
philippinisch für wühlen
hier gibt's badeanzüge
hazel und anita suchen bademode für
einen trip an einen der öffentlichen
strände dubais
ich bin fett das ist nichts für mich
ich bin nicht mehr sexy sie will an den
strand die vier gottes in der morgen
kostet eine bluse um die 100 die haben
hier kriegt man für 100 die haben sechs
bis zehn verschiedene sachen
100 dirham cent sprechen etwa 25 euro
dem arbeitslohn von zwei tagen
betont mein hüftspeck nein
das schlägt sich gut an
vielleicht lieber dass da
ihr flug ist zum einsteigen bereit danke
los gehts
nicht nur hazel geht auf schnäppchenjagd
auch keiner nutzt die zeit für einen
einkaufs quickie
das sollten wir nehmen das haben wir
noch nicht oder
das ist noch ein buch von scheich
mohammed wir haben zwar schon ein paar
seiner bücher aber dieses noch nicht
können wir im flieger lesen
ein hin und rückflug mit einem privatjet
nach großbritannien kostet an die 90.000
euro rund 150 mal so viel wie ein
economy ticket
wird das alles an
ich nehme diese schokolade rote und
blaue
ich weiß sie mal all die tollen
hygieneartikeln mama da ist noch mehr
schokolade
ich glaube es nicht alle meine lieblings
sachen
der ganze luxus hat seine vor und
nachteile
unsere tochter hat glück so aufwachsen
zu dürfen aber wenn man rund um die uhr
von so viel reichtum umgeben ist das
kann für die kinder auch ein nachteil
sein sie sieht mich nie beim waschen
oder bügeln
deshalb versuche ich ihr zu vermitteln
dass wir großes glück haben und dass
nicht alle menschen so leben wie wir
[Musik]
oder es wird dir gut stehen nein
vielleicht lieber für eins deiner kinder
hazel überweist fast ihren gesamten lohn
nach hause damit ihr sohn studieren kann
aber mein sohn soll später einmal ein
besseres leben haben als ich
mein mann verdient nicht so viel
deshalb musste ich hierher kommen um zu
arbeiten
und das hier weil sie so viel arbeiten
muss sieht sie ihren sohn seit seinem
ersten geburtstag nur einmal im jahr sie
müssen ihren sohn vermissen stimmt aber
wir telefonieren oder machen videoanrufe
aber ich mache nicht so oft videoanrufe
ich muss dann immer weinen und das will
ich nicht
ja so
sank das wirkt sich auf die arbeit aus
wenn man einsam ist und heimweh hat
ich habe nur einen sohn
und er ist schon 20
aber wie ich war viel zu lange weg
neben das lange kleid
das leben ist hart naja ich muss viel
arbeiten
aber die arbeit in dubai macht wirklich
spaß vor allem weil ich sehr nette
arbeitgeber gefunden habe die sind
wirklich einmalig sie haben einen platz
[Musik]
sagen wir so was geht zusammen ja was
geht und dann sagst du moniques ok
ist manni kriegs mit einem neuen video
noch eins nach noch ein video mein gott
[Applaus]
wir haben die ganze truppe hier also los
sehen wir uns das auto an
vor einer woche hatte der 19-jährige
mann eqix seinen lieblings rolls royce
in die werkstatt gebracht es soll im
farbton electric blue poliert werden
heute ist der große tag für die
enthüllung hat er ein paar freunde
mitgebracht die das event für seinen
youtube channel filmen sind bereit wir
sind bereit in
einer stadt wie dubai wo luxusschlitten
nichts besonderes sind braucht man etwas
einzigartiges um aufzufallen
oh
mein gott
die enthüllung seines gepimpten autos
wird ihm hunderttausende youtube klicks
einbringen das wird die leute plötzlich
sagte
was meinst du bro der wahnsinn wahnsinn
man epix ohnehin der reichste teenager
dubais wird noch reicher werden
sie werden ihre hälse verdrehen total
und auch ihre füße wenn sie daran
vorbeilaufen
aber so einzigartig wie man epix es
haben wollte ist das ganze dann doch
nicht es gibt noch mehr electric blue
diese befahrbar
wie gefällt ihnen oder ich liebe diese
farbe sonst hätte ich sie ja nicht
genommen als er sie sich aussuchte
dachte ich mir wie nehme ich auch und
zwar zuerst also habe ich meinen wagen
zuerst gemacht noch vor seine aber bitte
nicht weitersagen
und hole ich die gegend fahren
sie wolle wollte was spezielles
was braucht man mehr